today's video is kindly sponsored by
brightsellers a monthly wine club that
matches you with wine that you'll love
find out more later in the video
hey 42 here if you're old enough to
drink alcohol you've probably had one of
those nights where one minute you're in
a bar drunkenly chatting away with your
friends and the next thing you know
you're waking up in bed with a splitting
headache and a big mac stuck to your
cheek now imagine that same scenario but
this time instead of waking up in your
lovely comfortable bed you wake up in
the damp confines of a merchant ship
hundreds of miles from home with the
ship's captain towering over you
demanding that you go and scrub the poop
deck
the good news is the poop deck isn't an
area of the ship reserved for bowel
movements it's the bit built on top of
what is usually the captain's cabin at
the back of the ship
the odds name comes from the french word
for stern
the bad news is you've been kidnapped
and are being forced to work as a sailor
a situation that could last for months
maybe even years
unfortunately it's the 17th century so
you can't just whip your phone out and
call the police
not that it would make any difference if
you could because
believe it or not
this kind of kidnapping was perfectly
legal
well
mostly
welcome to the strange world of crimping
and no this video has nothing to do with
hairstyles
people always say you should enjoy the
little things in life and for me that's
opening a new bottle of red wine and
finding out it's just perfect for my
taste buds and that's exactly why i like
bright cellars brightsellers is a wine
box experience that matches you with
wines from all over the world curated to
your palate and with hundreds of private
label wines you'll be able to try a new
wine that you've never tasted before
bright sellers does all this by giving
you a quick and simple seven question
quiz with fun questions like what's your
favorite chocolate this will outline
your taste preferences and make sure
they deliver wines that you're just
guaranteed to love but it's not just
about drinking the wine what i love most
about bright cellars is you can easily
educate yourself on the wines you're
drinking thanks to the wine education
cards that come with every bottle they
outline the tasting notes suggested
pairings optimal serving temperature and
origin making you the ultimate at home
wine connoisseur bright sellers is a
five star experience for me i think
their wine service personalization
convenience and sustainability are all
unbeatable and bright sellers have been
extremely generous because they're
offering my viewers 60
off your first four bottle box
all you need to do is follow the link in
the description below to take the quiz
and get started today
thanks
crimping also known as shanghaiing as
many of the kidnapped people ended up
being shipped to shanghai
was essentially an act of finding
sailors for understaffed ships
in the 17th 18th and 19th centuries when
crimping was common practice
trade routes and naval operations
underpinned the backbone of the american
economy and seasoned sailors were always
in short supply that made crimping
essential if the cogs of the maritime
machine were to continue turning it also
meant crimping was an extremely
lucrative business with some so-called
crimps earning as much as 9
500 a year
that's around a quarter of a million
dollars in today's money that's a lot of
cash but in many cases the money was
well earned
you see
people weren't exactly queuing around
the block for the chance to sail the
seven seas that's because
life at sea during the age of sale was
well
a bit sh
ships were often infested with rats food
was scarce disease was rife and to rub
sea water into the wound
the pay was awful if you were brave
enough to complain about any of this
general misery the repercussions were
harsh
punishments for disobedience included
being tarred and feathered whipped with
the dreaded qatar nine tails or for more
serious infringements
death by hanging
fortunately for the crimps most ships
captains were desperate enough for hands
on deck that they'd accept almost anyone
on their crew
that meant pretty much any able-bodied
man was worth shanghaine but of course
simply asking a random passerby if they
fancied a life of back-breaking labor
aboard some random ship
wasn't especially effective
which meant crimps had to get creative
one of the more common techniques
employed was to buy an old dilapidated
building near the waterfront and turn it
into a boarding house
once open the crimp would entice local
vagrants inside by offering them some
kind of irresistible stay now pay later
offer
then all they had to do was sit back and
watch as their tenants racked up a debt
they'd never be able to pay back
at that point the crimp would simply
inform the unlucky soul
that they were legally required to join
the crew of one of the many ships
waiting in the nearby harbour in order
to pay back their debt
in return for supplying him with a brand
spanking new crew member the ship's
captain would pay off the debt along
with a bonus for the crimp known as
blood money
that might sound like a lot of pay for
an inexperienced crew member and it
would have been
except the payments would then be
deducted from the sailors future wages
everyone was a winner well except the
person who was forced to endure a life
of misery at sea
completely against their will
as the need for sailors grew crimps
began resorting to even more nefarious
methods in order to meet the increasing
demand setting up a fake boarding house
was all well and good
but it took time
some crimps sought faster methods
including befriending people in bars
before spiking their drinks with opium
once the victim was out for the count
they would be wrapped up in a canvas
tarp taken to the harbour
and sold like fish at a market store
as you can imagine it took a certain
caliber of person to do that kind of
work you didn't last long as a crimp if
you concerned yourself too much with
silly things like morals or other
people's feelings
and when it came to not giving a toss
about other people
nobody came close to portland's king of
the crimps
englishman
joseph bunco kelly
a man who claimed to have crimped 2 000
men and women over the course of his
15-year career
kelly arrived in portland sometime in
the late 1800s and soon gained a
reputation as an expert con man who
would do just about anything to make a
fast book
the word bunko is a 19th century term
for a con and kelly more than earns that
nickname
on one memorable occasion when he'd
found himself unable to locate a
suitable victim to shanghai
he resorted to selling a life-sized
wooden statue of a native american known
at the time as a cigar store indian
wrapped up in a tarp
by the time the oblivious skipper had
unwrapped the body to discover a wooden
statue instead of an able-bodied seamen
the ship had already set sail and kelly
was back on dry land with 50 dollars in
his pocket
but kelly's most revered con
would happen after a chance encounter
with a bungled robbery
whilst walking through the streets of
portland in the dead of night he came
across an open cellar door
being the opportunist that he was
kelly decided to take a sneaky peek
inside
and there lying unconscious on the floor
were around 20 men
kelly couldn't believe his luck
if you're wondering why 20 men happened
to be unconscious in a random seller it
transpired they'd recently broken in
believing it belonged to the saloon
above
unfortunately for them but fortunately
for kelly
it actually belongs to the local
undertakers and all that lovely booze
they thought they'd been drinking was in
fact embalming fluid
by the time they'd realized their
mistake it was far too late
kelly had struck crimping gold a gift
from father chrimpmus himself
a ready-made shipment of sailors who had
even gone to the trouble of rendering
themselves unconscious for ease of
transport
kelly didn't waste any time he took the
men down to the docks where he sold them
for 52 dollars apiece to the captain of
a ship called the flying prince
unfortunately for the captain it turns
out that downing embalming fluid is
liable to give you much more than a
headache and when he calls for all hands
on deck sometime later
he discovered his new crew was dead to a
man
[Music]
it's worth pointing out that some
historians dispute the validity of
stories like these
for obvious reasons
but whether or not the finer points have
been embellished over the years
there's no denying that kelly was an
exceptional crimp
he was even deemed worthy to work
alongside the head of portland's largest
crimping empire
larry sullivan
sullivan was a former prize fighter who
turned to a life of crimping after a
brutal
75-round boxing match had
unsurprisingly left him considering his
retirement options
but sullivan was no mindless
he had brains to match his brawn he
essentially unified portland's unruly
crimping scene and turned it into a
well-oiled machine with him at the hell
this rise to power meant sullivan made
many friends in high places and soon
found himself rubbing shoulders with
portland's political elite to begin with
kelly and sullivan seemed to make the
perfect team
but one thing always stood between
politics
kelly was a staunch democrat and
sullivan a republican and it wouldn't
take long for these political
differences to cause friction between
the two men
[Music]
the resentment came to a head when the
leader of the oregon republican party
was tried for his alleged involvement in
an industrial scale opium smuggling
operation not only did kelly appear as a
witness for the prosecution he also made
the mistake of testifying that he was in
partnership with sullivan being
associated with the prosecution of an
important republican risked damaging
sullivan's political connections and
when he confronted kelly about the trial
the ensuing argument is said to have
developed into a street fight that saw
the two men being arrested and thrown
into jail
soon after their release kelly was
accused of murdering an elderly man in a
botched shanghaiing attempt after the
man's body was found partially
dismembered in a nearby river
kelly protested his innocence claiming
he'd been framed by sullivan and there's
every chance he was telling the truth
after all it seems unlikely that a man
who'd spent his life perfecting the art
of crimping
would struggle to kidnap a pensioner
not to mention the fact that the corpse
in question had been found wearing a
solid gold watch i mean come on kelly
was a guy who'd probably shanghai his
own grandmother the idea he'd pass upon
the opportunity to steal a perfectly
good gold watch from a lifeless corpse
seems a bit of a stretch but
unfortunately for kelly his look had run
out he was sentenced to life behind bars
the commotion surrounding the murder
resulted in kelly's notoriety peaking
and in all likelihood it's for this
reason his infamy rose above the many
other crimps in operation during his
time
kelly was eventually released some 13
years later at which point he attempted
to take his career in a new direction by
writing a book about his experiences
behind bars but the book was a flop and
defeated and penniless
bunco kelly faded into obscurity
by the early 20th century the tables had
begun to turn on the practice of
shanghaiing
over the years new laws had gradually
stacked up that made the life of a crimp
increasingly difficult
the emergence of steam-powered boats
also meant crews were becoming smaller
and ships had less need for
unskilled deck hands
by 1915 shanghaiing was finally made
illegal all across the us
so next time you wake up feeling a
little worse for wear after a night out
perhaps you can take some solace in the
fact that as bad as you may feel at
least you haven't woken up on some
random ship destined for shanghai
[Music]
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us it's a wild and
witty journey for a thousand years of
unexpected roman history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in
thank you